hello everyone about the Fisher faced
three very strong opponents before he
will earned the right to challenge Boris
Spassky for the title he defeated mark
diamond of inventor Larsson with a
result of six to zero and then he
defeated the former world champion
Tigran Petrosian with a result of six
and a half to two and a half so pretty
much crushing the field and this is the
mo probably the most famous match ever
held in chess this is the 1972 chess
match in Reykjavik Iceland Bobby Fischer
vs. Boris Spassky and well there was a
whole lot of drama
prior to this match but you know saying
everything that happened would require a
very long video or even a video of its
own so I'm just going to keep it short
nobody really even knew if Bobby would
come to Iceland D let alone play the
match and well the match was almost
about to start and Fischer did show up
and of course Fischer presented the
organizers with his requests and the
requests were pretty usual you know the
color of the pieces well board will be
used what feats will be used what tables
what cushions and you know what not what
lighting and there was also the issue of
the price fund Fischer requested a lot
more money and this was this wasn't such
an easy task to complete but there was
this guy called James Slater he was a
British chess promoter and he donated
one hundred and twenty-five thousand
dollars to be added to the prize fund
which was a whole lot of money back then
for chess I mean Spassky often said that
he doesn't regret becoming a
professional chess player but he
probably could have made a lot more
money if he continues his journalism
career so yeah oh and you know pretty
quickly most of all I mean all Bobby's
Bobby's demands were met but Bobby still
wasn't really sure if you wanted to play
Spassky or not and well some
convincingly took place by his second
will in one party and you all probably
know about the famous phone call Bobby
received from Henry Kissinger and well
in the end the Bobby did decide to play
Spassky and the game I'm going to show
you is game number six but a couple of
things in game number one it was a
completely wrong
in game but Bobby Fischer well he
grabbed that poison pawn in the ending
and Spassky trapped his Bishop and well
Bobby was the first game and then he
said that well the cameras were too loud
he couldn't play he couldn't focus and
he refused to play and well he was
forfeited in Game two
so it's already 2 to 0 for Spassky and
Bobby still doesn't want to play the
match and well the Soviets are already
celebrating as Bobby Fischer was almost
completely forfeited from the match but
this is why considered Boris Spassky to
be such a great gentleman Boris Spassky
agreed to play Fischer on any term
Fischer had and he agreed to play Bobby
Fischer in a small room behind the
backstage or with no cameras and a lot
of people think that this was possibly
the greatest mistake but I really
respect Spassky for doing this and
that's exactly the place where Bobby
Fischer defeated Boris Spassky for the
first time in his life and well after
that game they returned to the main
stage although the cameras were removed
and after after those two games that
Bobby lost well in the next 19 games for
the rest of the match Bobby Fischer lost
only only one game all the others were
either drawn or in Bobby's favor so this
is this is game 6 and the results here
is two and a half each between half
points each so you know it's a very
important who wins this game will get
the lead and Bobby Bobby plays it
interestingly from new one because you
know when when you hear Bobby Fischer
you probably think ok
efore but this game he actually played 1
c4 and he never played c4 he did plays
ok a couple of times but I don't think
he ever won a game with c4
so using this in a World Championship
matches you know quite the deal we have
E 6 by Boris Spassky Knight to f3 b5 and
here another you know cheeky move but
Bobby plays d4 goes to the Queens gambit
declined which you know this Spassky
strongpoint Knight to f6 Knight to c3
Bishop to e7 Bishop to g5 castles III h6
and this is all standard theory
Bishop to h4 and now bb6 and again
Bobbi's cheeky here because this is the
talk of a variation of the Queens gambit
declined and the spots can never lost a
game in this variation so he's really
challenging him and well okay here Bobby
goes for a series of trades but he has
an idea why he does it
he plays seek after some d5 Knight
captures and e5 Bishop captures any
seven Queen captures ninety-seven Knight
captures on d5 and II kept her son d5
and he plays rook the c1 we have Bishop
to e6 by Spassky and now he plays Queen
to a4 and when you look at this squint a
for a move I mean I remember the first
time I saw this move it was really weird
I mean what's the queen doing there but
also it felt like it was a very powerful
move probably because it was favorable
plated but well nevertheless we have c5
by Spassky and I'll point to a3
Bobby places his Queen to a3 and now
uses this pin because the Queen I'm a
seven is undefended we have roped the c8
and Bishop to b5 Bobby develops his
favorite piece on a very active square
and well this is the position that
caused much debate over the years and
it's probably debated still now
Spassky played a six here attacking the
bishop and b5 but it's interesting that
Spassky second Geller he played the
Queen to b7 here in a lot of his game
since he had you know great success with
this move and well no no one knew if
spots he didn't remember this or they
didn't really prepare for anything other
than d4 because you know what's Bobby's
going to play but e for so Spassky
played a six here and this gives Fischer
time to to now improve the position he
plays big answers on c5 because well the
bishop cannot be captured yes the rook
will be captured by the Queen we have V
captures on c5 and now Fischer castles
and now rook the a7 now defending the
Queen also Queen defends the rook and
Bobby plays the Bishop to e2 getting the
bishop out of harm's way and this is a
team you'll see often in Bobby's games
first he develops his light-square
bishop then he brings him back and well
then he activates him later in the game
where when he will be a lot more
powerful we have nice to d7 nice to d4
now Fisher again exploits this pin on
the Queen so basically it's probably you
know already tired of this place going
to f8 and now there another pin is no
longer here and Fisher plays a very nice
idea he played tonight captures on e6 we
have F captures on e6 and now II for a
very nice pawn sacrifice but there's
really no point in accepting this pawn
because you'll have a double spawns on D
file and you know a an alone poem on the
C file and Fischer will collect these
pretty soon so as basket decides to push
d4 and create a path spawn which is
which is a good move and Fischer
immediately goes f4 he wants the you
know strengthen this g5 squared not
allow 95 or any 5 right ideas we have
Queen t7 by Spassky and now e 5 and now
you see that well
Fischer grabbed a lot more space with
this move and also he fixed this week
ecig spawn on this square and guess
who's gonna guess who's coming for that
point we have a nice we have rook to b8
and now Bishop to c4
of course Fischer uses the bishop now
and now the bishop is very strong on c4
and this is this is a great move because
it's played with a tactic Spassky was
really enjoy playing Knight to b6 here
but it's nice to be six the you know
threatened the bishop and prepare the
pushing of the points and then simply
Queen captures and c5 and if Queen
captures and Bishop captures on e6 with
a check and a discovery on the Queen and
this is a well a lot better for white
probably even winning so after Bishop to
c4 we have King 2hh getting out of the
pin and now Fischer plays another
beautiful move Queen to h3 using the
whole board from a 3 to h3 and as
possibly decides well okay the Knights
not really going to be useful and on the
Queen side let's let's go Knight to
efface to protect this
c6 pawn and favorite place b3 and okay
there is nothing really coming through
this this is this is a beautiful
blockade we have a a 5 and Spassky is
thinking about playing a 4 but Fisher
doesn't bother with a for himself he
pushes f5 immediately we have it
captures on f5 and our rook captures on
f5 and nice h7 preparing nice to g5 and
also you know adding some protection to
this f6 square we have a rook c2 f1 not
doubling up on the F file and Queen to
d8 so it's a good move it prepares this
rook for entering the game and also
maybe in some variations you know if you
can push this D pawn supposed plays
Queen to g3 also adding pressure here
and kind of eyeing that row can be 8 we
have rook to e7
and I'll fish replace h4 and allowing
that nice to get any g5 ideas Group B -
b7 and officer plays C 6 with a with a
nice idea
rugby - c7 Queen to e5 we have Queen to
e8 and Spassky if you look at this
position doesn't really have a move here
it's a very passive position and he has
to wait for Bobby to do something we
have a 4 now completely solidifying
because pasta was kind of threatening to
play for himself Queen to d8 we have
rook 1 to s 2
Queen tv8 rook to to f3 Queen to d8 and
now Bishop to d3 we have 28 and now
Queen's the e4 and now spot we cannot
repeat moves anymore if spot he played
something like Queen to d8 then disrupt
f8 check would be game over after Knight
captures rook captures Queen captures
Queen to h7 would be checkmate
so after Queen t4 and the well preparing
and ice trap Spassky plays Knight to f6
abacus is just what Fischer was going
for all his pieces on our IR on ideal
places and he plays rook captures and f6
very nice very nice exchange sacrifice
we have G captures on f6 now rook
captures on f6 King to g8 and Bishop to
c4 now solidifying some more akin to a
chase and we have
into f4 and in this position Spassky
resigned there are simply too many
threats
well the despawn on h6 can be captured
rooked roughly f8 is a threat so any
move played by Spassky let's say Quincy
eight runs in the Queen to e5 and there
is no way to the stop to stop all the
discoveries if rotate 7 because Fischer
is always a threat and rook captures on
h6 with instant checkmate if he stops
isn't simply e6 and this as well the
queen is attacked and there are all
sorts of discoveries in the position and
this spots even tried to block this Ben
Fisher can even bring bring out another
queen so none of this ever happened
after after this Queen to f4 move as
possible resigned the game and yeah
Fisher Fisher got the lead and he didn't
he didn't lose the lead till the end of
the match and like I said after those
two games that Fischer lost okay he only
lost the first game second was forfeited
in the next 19 games he only lost one
game
it was a game 11 I believe and the final
result was a twelve and a half to eight
and a half so okay out of those three
challengers in the candidates Spassky
definitely gave him the most trouble so
yeah that's it I do hope you enjoyed
this game as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I will see you
soon maybe maybe even with another game
from this famous match see you around